does it tell you something deeper about  your team compared to yeah it tells us  we ain't we ain't  on their level  i mean  i've told you that before the game  started do you think you can reach that  level  where they are right now um i don't know  um  [Music]  do i think we can reach the level where  milwaukee is right now um  no  yeah would you that what you want to  hear about me  no  oh yeah you want to follow up right now  i will hope so but right now we don't  know we can't get to where they are  right now i mean  they're the defending champions for a  reason  and i get i guarantee if you were to ask  teams coming out of bubble if they could  get to the level that we were playing at  when we won a championship they said the  same thing